can you lie to your opponents in a game
of magic in order to win surprisingly
the answer isn't a straightforward yes
or no let's take a look at this from
earlier this year to set the scene the
players are playing in the Treasure
series number 11 a competitive Commander
tournament where first prize is worth
$600 the players we're about to see are
playing in the semi-finals now while it
wasn't captured on video the player in
the top right corner Cowboy Bob freely
mentioned at some point during this turn
cycle that they could not win the game
on their turn it's worth noting that
nobody asked them if they could win on
their turn or not they willingly gave up
that information the video starts with
Bob casting savin's Reclamation which
lets them return Target permanent with
Mana value three or less from the
graveyard to the
battlefield yeah what's your target
tarting
breach oh the
Li I don't know what I'm sorry I didn't
expect I honestly didn't see the line
until I started playing through it sure
yeah well you still could have kept your
word like you said I apologize I really
didn't see the line we're in top
cut I mean it doesn't make it okay to
lie um actually lying isn't against the
rules in this case okay okay before
everybody gets their pitchforks let's
make a few things perfectly clear there
are four types of information in Magic
status free derived and private status
information is information that must be
announced upon change and physically
tracked by affected players status
information includes life totals
counters a player has attached to them
continuous effects with no defined
expiration within the game that apply to
that player such as Monarch or the
city's blessing unspent Mana in that
player's Mana pool location in the
dungeon and how many times the ring has
tempted a player free information is
information that is available to both
players and cannot be misconstrued in
any way or lied about by either player
free information includes details of the
current game actions and P game actions
that still affect the game State the
name of any visible object the number
and types of counters that isn't defined
as status information the state and
current Zone of any object or player the
game score of the current match and the
current step and or phase and which
players are active next we're going to
cover derived information and private
information and this is where we get
into the Crux of this video and please
keep in mind all this information is
taken from the magic tournament rule
section from the magic judges. org site
this isn't my opinion these are the
literal rules of the game as of April
2024 derived information is defined as
information to which all players are
entitled access but opponents are not
obliged to assist in determining and may
require some skill or calculation to
determine derived information includes
the number of any type of objects
present in any game Zone that are not
defined as free information all
characteristics of objects in public
zones that are not defined as free or
status information game rules tournament
policy Oracle content and any other
official information pertaining to the
current tournament the magic judges
article points out that a player is not
obliged to assist their opponent with
the game rules tournament policy Oracle
text or any other official information
pertaining to the current tournament
giving this example if a player asks
their opponent what a card does a player
does not have to give all of the
information about the card their
opponent may say that a vampire
Nighthawk is a 23 flying creature and
omit that it has death touch and
LifeLink what derived information
essentially boils down to is a player
needs to be able to read and assess a
board state by themselves using the free
and Status information however they can
ask a judge at any time with help
determining free and Status information
including Oracle text on cards but the
judge must avoid aist existing players
with derived information about the game
State here's another interesting example
if my opponent has a tago and a number
of cards in their graveyard they are not
obliged to tell me Tag's power and
toughness and neither is a judge it is
up to me to work out how many different
permanent types there are in all
graveyards and finally we have private
information which is effectively
everything that is not free or derived
information for example example the
contents of a player's hand library or
identity of any face down card in a
public Zone interestingly the rules note
that players are allowed to give their
opponents false information about the
contents of hidden zones so if I have
two untapped Islands I'm free to tell my
opponents I have counter spell in hand
even if I don't another interesting
example the article gives is that if my
opponent casts Slaughter games and they
name esape shift I can tell my opponent
that I only have three copies in my
library while they're searching through
it even if it actually contains four now
there are some caveats to these
information types to keep in mind too
players must answer honestly any
specific questions pertaining to free
information players may not misrepresent
derived free or status information
incorrectly this would include hiding
the forest version of dried Arbor
amongst your lands not making it clear
which cards are in Exile or in your
graveyard or how many cards you have in
hand and at regular rules enforcement
level all derived information is instead
considered free
information to clarify that last point
there are three different levels of
tournaments and each of them slightly
change the way that the rules are
governed at the event at events like F&M
and pre-release the rules enforcement
level is set to regular this is because
these sorts of events are more focused
on the fun social and learning aspects
of the game education and sportsmanship
are the priority here the key thing here
is that at regular enforcement level
derived information is instead
considered free information so in the
tamago or Nighthawk example my opponent
would have to truthfully tell me what
Tag's power and toughness is and make
sure nothing is emitted from nigh Hawk's
description if I ask at event with
significant cash prizes or invitations
to professional tournaments the rules
enforcement is set to competitive
players are expected to know the game's
rules and be familiar with tournament
policies and procedures but
unintentional errors are not punished
severely basically players aren't at
these tournaments to muck around they're
here to win and unfortunately not hold
their opponent's hands through every
step events at this level would include
things like wpn and Pro Tour
qualifiers and finally at the biggest
magic tournaments in the world as you
would expect these events are enforced
at professional level these tournaments
hold players to their highest standards
so events like worlds and the second day
of the Grand Prix so with all that
knowledge in mind if we look back at the
treasure series event they're playing
for a cash prize they're playing in a
format called
cedh also known as competitive EDH so
it's safe to assume they're playing at
competitive rules level enforcement
meaning as long as Cowboy Bob didn't
misconstrue any free information they
were well within their rights to do what
they did the magic tournament rules also
state that while players are willing to
do whatever they can to win judges need
to make sure players behave within the
rules bluffing is okay for example but
we cannot condone any behavior that
crosses the line into cheating or other
unsportsmanlike conduct on top of that
there is also a magic card that promotes
lying about what a player is about to do
prisoners dilemma is a card that was
released in Murders At Carlo Manor
Commander set in short players secretly
choose snitch or silence if everyone
chooses silence they each take four
damage if everyone chooses snitch they
each take eight damage now if there is a
mix of the two whoever chooses silence
takes 12 damage and those that chose
snitch will walk away damage free now on
the official release notes for the card
it says the following before secret
votes are revealed players May announce
how they intend to vote but they can't
reveal what they actually wrote down
until all votes are simultaneously
revealed players can lie about how they
intend to vote before the votes are
revealed so again lying and bluffing is
allowed in this game of wizard poker
you're up there oh you lied of course I
lied it's poker Phil what do you think
this is so here's my personal take on
the whole situation if I'm at a
tournament playing for cash prizes I'm
going to assume my opponent is going to
take every Edge within the rules to try
and win and I would expect them to
assume the same of me having said that I
have enough respect for my opponents
that if they ask me the power and
toughness of a tamag or something
similar I'm going to honestly and
truthfully tell them the answer now of
course if I'm playing casual Commander
with my friends outside of bluffing that
I have a counter spell or a board wipe
because I always end up being the arch
enemy there is absolutely no reason at
all to be lying about derived
information you're playing with your
friends surely you want to help them
become better players why on Earth would
I want to Salt their experience by
catching them out on a technicality
because I've been playing the game 15
years longer than them so what do you
think of this whole situation was Cowboy
Bob completely within his rights to do
what what they did as always if you
learned something be sure to like the
video and subscribe because if you don't
I'll tell you I'm picking silence and
then reveal snitch thanks for watching
and I'll see you in the next one